bonjour sarra el aissi bonjour vous êtes
candidate modem ou législative en
loire-atlantique qu'auparavant vous
étiez secrétaire d'état chargée de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement déçu de ne
pas être au gouvernement non pas du tout
et toujours une émotion je peux vous
mentir le jour où tu fais une passation
ben il ya quelque chose qui termine
après c'était la fin du quinquennat j'ai
eu la grande chance de faire le service
civique européen le service civique
écologique le service national universel
qui va accompagner toute une jeunesse
non le plus tôt le la sensation autres
aient le sentiment du devoir accompli
entre est une boucle a été bouclée et là
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir la confiance de
salon de la république pour faire
campagne alors le précédent gouvernement
il comptait cinq ministres modem n'a
plus que deux marc fesneau et la
secrétaire d'état en charge de la mer
justine bénin le modem avec mal servi
salut françois bayrou l'a dit lui-même
on n'est pas dans la culture ni date en
bouillie du chantage c'est pas notre
c'est pas notre manière d'être ce n'est
pas notre manière de faire
maintenant ça a été également dit c'est
un premier gouvernement il y aura
certainement un élargissement est
certainement ce bel ouvrage hier sur bfm
il aurait été heureux que nous puissions
être plus utile mais bien sûr mais on
peut être utile partout et ses essais et
c'est moi qui vous le dit d'ailleurs
parce que quand on est utile ou inutile
à l'assemblée nationale on à 101
candidats aujourd'hui qu'ils partent sur
le terrain pour apporter la majorité la
plus forte et la plus grande au
président de la république nous sommes
loyaux nous sommes exigeants certes mais
surtout je veux dire on n'est pas dans
la culture de tu me donnes je te donne
c'est pas la manière de faire rentrer à
nos trois maires après les législatives
rendez vous pour le groupe le plus
important le plus fort pour soutenir
notre projet le présent du présent de
près le projet du président de la
république à l'assemblée est
certainement nous l'espérons évidemment
une présence rentrer tard et au sein du
gouvernement l'a promis hier les rats de
nouvelles nominations elle l'a dit aux
responsables de gérer des gens suis j'en
suis ravi d'autant plus que vous savez
ce gouvernement là je le connais j'en
connais une partie puisque c'étaient mes
collègues sous le gouvernement de jean
castex ils sont engagés ils sont motivés
et ne lâche rien et je les connais donc
puisque c'est les miens si on vous
demande ce parti vous savez ça dépend
jamais de soi et mais ça a été un énorme
honneur j'ai 33 ans j'ai grandi au maroc
je suis né à romorantin rien ne
présageait à tout ça et pourtant le rêve
républicain ou en tout cas le mérite à
force de persévérance paye j'ai une
histoire d'engager d'abord syndicale
ensuite associatif militant de politique
bien sûr et dans le fond le plus utile
pour moi ma seule boussole c'est de
servir
vous l'avez dit vous avez été
gouvernement vous avez des parties de
comment vous expliquer aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe sur les retraites comment
vous l'expliquez à vos potentiels
électeurs parce que on a du mal à s'y
retrouver alors vous savez sur les
retraites mois sur le marché parce que
j'ai commencé à en faire beaucoup aidé
porte à porte et se trouve que hier
j'étais à cas sont une petite commune au
nord au nord de nantes magnifique
qu'elle devrait dans une identité
extrêmement forte c'est simple le projet
des retraites c'est pour garantir
aujourd'hui notre petit trésor qui est
celui du conseil national de la
résistance c'est la retraite par
répartition on a une réalité qui est on
est passé de quatre actifs à un actif et
demi ça veut dire quoi concrètement il
ya trois hypothèses on baisse les
pensions c'est hors de question on
augmente les cotisations c'est hors de
question eh bien on peut travailler à
l'allongement de la durée à l'oreille
mais un bonheur y compris que ça serait
légale car s'était même dit dans la
campagne et maintenant on parle de
l'allongement de durée de cotisation
oui la vérité est bien la vérité elle
sera dans le dialogue social je voulais
dit je suis une ancienne responsable
syndicale au sein de la cftc le dialogue
social c'est pas une paille c'est même
la garantie et la nécessité qu'un projet
comme celui-là créer l'adhésion du pays
vous savez françois fillon l'a dit
lui-même et s'il faut avec jurés clair
s'il faut aller jusqu'au référendum on
ira jusqu'au référendum mais on est on
le sait sur une réforme difficile c'est
tout de suite qu'il faut y aller c'est
pas tergiversé ceni tergiverser ni
considérer qu'on n'ira pas tout de suite
c'est à partir de septembre ça a été
rappelé par olivier dussopt tu des ceux
d hier mais surtout il faut aller
chercher la réforme la plus juste
possible et pour ça eh bien oui il faut
prendre le temps de la concertation avec
les aubades syndicale avec les parties
prenantes ya la question du chômage des
seniors et à la question de la
rémunération des fins de carrière et la
question des aidants et à la question si
de la pénible tu es bien vous savez moi
je crois que oui si ça il faut pas
mélanger au final le message il est il
est dans la méthode message il est clair
nous voulons sauver absolument la
retraite qui aura les partitions
absolument là encore par avion on veut
protéger les plus vulnérables on veut
augmenter les plus petits traits les
plus petites retraites a au minimum 1100
euros
la traversée est dans la tourmente le
gouvernement aussi par ricochet comment
fixer des règles claires
les règles elles sont toujours
extrêmement clair puisque nous sommes
dans un état de droit il n'ya pas une
règle qui changent que l'on soit
ministre aux citoyens que l'on soit
ancien ministre et lui il n'ya il y à
une seule et unique règle celle de
l'état de droit ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que quand on est victime eh
bien il faut absolument déposé plainte
avoir le soutien le plus fort de tous
ceux qui nous représentent ça veut dire
lutter côté violence sexuelle et sexiste
cdn lutter contre les inégalités ces
exemples pareils à la morlande lavera
gouvernement est mise en cause eh bien
il faut que la justice pose sa vérité
faut qu'elle tranche pour qu'elle donne
sa réalité et prendre chaque prise
chaque parole quelle qu'elle soit au
sérieux et c'est pour ça que aussi bien
la parole je sais bien que c'est de les
aider des pays qui se déclare victime et
bien sûr vous savez moi je suis ni pro
commence la justice la justice est le
seul à six mètres de haut a pas de
règles gouvernementales adoptées à
clarifier exemplarité et tranchée par la
justice parce que ça dit la valeur de la
parole d'une grogne qui s'ouvre pour
narguer sur un poison l'avis du
gouvernement de la semaine ce qui est
certain c'est que la vérité devra être
établie factuellement moi ce que je sais
où de manière objective c'est qu'en 2012
y avait une peine une une affaire qui a
été complice suisse ensuite en 2017 ça a
été pareil sauf que il ya une motion
allemand vient à nouveau alors il faut
la mise en lumière mais jamais s'amuse
et apprendre à se prendre ni pour un
procureur de la république ni pour un
policier mais pour un ordinateur bas
débit donc j'avais commandé jamais donc
il doit pas démissionner à moi je pense
que la justice devra mettre en lumière
et d'ailleurs a été assez clair elle a
dit si la justice est saisie s'il ya des
informations nouvelles alors on en
tirera toutes les conséquences
le préfet d'isère a référé contre
l'autorisation du burkini à grenoble il
est examiné aujourd'hui par le tribunal
distractif les maires demandent une
clarification aussi les associations des
maires de france est prononcé comment
faire moi je crois que en tout cas vous
savez je suis conseillère municipale à
nantes et si demain une proposition
comme ça arriver dans mon conseil
municipal je voterai absolument contre
je considère que le burkina n'est ni un
immense et batteur ni une avancée dans
notre notre pays je crois que au
contraire ils naples à sa place au sein
de nos piscines municipales ou sur sur
nos plages maintenant j'ai hâte d'avoir
s'est arrêtée même si j'ai une position
très claire je l'espère il sera pour la
sur l'interdiction du burkini et des
arrêtés de ses pleurs c'est pas si
simple ce n'est pas si simple puisque la
question qui se pose pour être encore
plus explicite il faut veiller sur
l'hygiène et la sécurité ce qu'il faut
être sur une question de principe de
vivre ensemble dans ce sont ceux sont
les juristes qui poseront l'écriture on
va dire étayé plus légal moi ce que je
sais est fondamentalement ce que je
crois c'est que il faut il ne faut pas
aller mettre des coups de canif dans des
étangs déséquilibre d'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes mais je considère
que le burqini aujourd'hui c'est un lion
le droit des marques d'habitation
politique aussi je pense moi je suis pas
je suis pas naïve je vois un calendrier
politique particulier il se trouve que
le maire de grenoble choisi un moment
très particulier pour relancer ce débat
là je trouve que sa fracture ça ne crée
pas d'unité dans le pays alors même que
nous avons besoin de nouveaux progrès
nous avons besoin d'apaisement nous
avons besoin de dialogue nous a besoin
de rassemblement et c'est certainement
pas en avion alors la polémique que vous
êtes vous êtes effectivement une
fervente défenseur de la laïcité vous
avez travaillé avec jean michel blanquer
comment vous interprétez la nomination
de pap ndiaye moi je suis très fier de
travail qu'on a fait que j'ai un blanc
caire le vade-mecum de la laïcité le
service national universel grand
défenseur et grands projets qui mènera
je pense une jeunesse avoir conscience
de ce trésor qu'est la laïcité l'arrivée
de pape ndiaye pour moi je la vois comme
finalement une nouvelle ou peut-être
méthode dans la manière de travailler à
180 degrés non la méthode peut être
nouvelle parce que ce n'est pas les deux
c'est pas les mêmes peuples ce n'est pas
les mêmes histoires ça c'est certain
mais j'ai beau aussi peut-être une
chance un élan au de raison toute simple
c'est qu'il portera le projet de la
preuve la république et c'est ça en
réalité le l'essentiel même j'ai eu une
passation avec lui avec également jean
michel blanquer j'ai posé nos priorités
nos projets l'importance que je donnais
évidemment ils ont les sages avaient
renvoyé il est quand même passer le
message il est celui d'un pur produit de
l'école républicaine
celui qui s'est élevé par l'école et qui
avait des propos oui en tant que
l'université historiens mais qui peuvent
prêter à
ce sujet à caution qui peuvent être
interprétées comme une porte ouverte
vers des colonialistes dès le moment où
il est arrivé sur le perron ça faisait
pas trois minutes qu'il était là et que
on était en train de l'accueillir qu'il
y avait été qualifiée de 15 16 17
qualificatifs moi ce que je crois alors
c'est des preuves c'est des actes
la première premier déplacement de pap
ndiaye iléades agence avaler au goal
dans les crânes malfatti où il ya eu ce
drame est ce cet acte terroriste cela
pour appeler les choses telles qu'app ce
symbole est fort exactement et
maintenant ce que j'attends de voir
c'est évidemment et bien la suite des
actes forts des propositions de fortes
il a parlé de république il a parlé de
nationaux nations unies lors de sa
passion moi ça me batte au coeur parce
que fondamentalement et bien j'aime la
france j'aime la république mais ça se
défend merci sahara et la grille
[Musique]